should a new writer look at writing as a
fun endeavor
or should they really check themselves
in the beginning and say
okay is this something i want to take on
the time commitment
time away from maybe friends and family
maybe there are going to be parts that
won't be so
joyous uh it's a great question and um
yeah absolutely do it because it's fun
there's no other reason to do it and if
it's not completely fun
do anything else you know find what is
fun
for you if there was something that was
a hobby for you
that you loved but you didn't want to
take it on as
a career could you say the same for
writers maybe they just want to write
for the sheer joy of it for creating
characters
but they don't want the pressure of
having to pitch and have
to pay their car payment based on
whether they sell a script or not
yeah of course yeah yeah no that's um
one of the most satisfying experiences i
get from
writing yeah the fact that i get paid
well
to write is separate from my experience
of
of writing i mean if i didn't make a
dime from anything i wrote the rest of
my life
i would still write i mean it's because
it's it's so
deeply satisfying in terms of executing
my vision for how life occurs to me
what are my deepest challenges what are
my um
what are the insights that have sort of
gotten me through different parts of my
life how do i
how do i make a transformation from this
stage to that stage i mean that's what
we do in any screenplay and if i'm
writing about an astronaut or this or
that
um you know i've never been an astronaut
but i've written about several
um but it's the emotional journey of
those characters that's
it's as personal to me as if i'm writing
in a journal so
um if somebody is drawn to screenwriting
for the sheer joy of it that's
absolutely what they should be doing and
they
and nobody really should be worrying
about the money side of it if it's
so fun for you to write
a screenplay and so fun for you to share
it with
anybody and so fun for them to say i
love it
and so fun for them
to sort of give you feedback and so fun
for you to take that feedback and find a
way to serve them
even better and so fun to keep that
going
then absolutely that person should allow
the professional
part of it to come to them and if they
stop at any point in that path and
they're happy just writing it for
themselves and showing it to nobody
that's great i mean it's really about
what makes them happy
is that the litmus test is it fun yeah
really so is that how you approach most
things in life though it has to be where
it's not creating huge amounts of stress
for you yeah
um absolutely i read a wonderful book
years ago
about ben and jerry's ice cream company
um
i love i loved it so much i cried when i
finished uh
reading it and it was because they to my
mind
had a beautiful vision of fun and
business you know it's show and its
business
and the way they articulated it was this
double bottom line
anything they did had had to be fun and
it had to be profitable
right um and the truth is um
if you approach it the right way um you
absolutely can do both
and if you're not seeing the way to do
both have something be profitable and
lucrative
and fun and easy you're not looking in
the right direction it's probably like
right behind you you got to turn around
and
look someplace else but it really is and
how
in my writing process or my life
certainly things come up and it feels
there's a resistance or something's not
easy and then that's just a reminder to
go dude
it's you know you're this is you're
forcing it it's too much and then i go
okay well what's the easy what's the
easy way
what's the easy way and that's
oftentimes it's stopping and breathing
or
we're not thinking about it think about
something else that is easy in the
moment and then going to that
um and then um
when i hold those spaces open the easy
ways come
have you had people challenge you
students mentees that say
work isn't supposed to be fun aside from
this interview where i'm
playing the devil's advocate i love it
well it's um
i mean that's the standard right so um
uh and and and
so it's where and and people are
people have to i can sit here and tell
them this or that or the other
and uh they they need to figure it out
for themselves
and they need to try it if they're
interested and not try it if they're not
interested
it's not right for them if they hear it
it's too crazy and
you know that's fine so um i have no
interest
in um uh convincing
somebody of anything i mean if i you
know when i used to teach this class at
uc
ucla extension i would absolutely speak
to these ideas
um and they wouldn't really challenge me
i'm sure some people were
very skeptical and some people were flat
out like that's crazy that can't work
and
that's fine you know it certainly can't
work for them if that's the way they
think
um and um it might work for you
even if you're skeptical if you try it
and you say okay i think it's probably
not going to work but i'm going to be
open to it
and i might try it and you see and what
will happen
at least in my experience is um a
it feels better and if nothing else if
the ah if there's no
law of attraction if it's all hui and um
the odds of something happening are
exactly the same
but your approach to life feels better
and you've got the same odds it's worth
doing it so
my invitation to anybody who's skeptical
is i honor the skepticism
try it out see if you enjoy it more see
if the odds are at least the same
of getting what you want as soon as you
want and
and see if you don't have the experience
that i've had and i've seen
pretty much everybody that embraces the
theory have you actually get things
faster because i'm
open to opportunities in a way that's
different when i'm closed off and i'm
focused on oh
crap this is going to happen i'm scared
of that or this didn't happen or i'm not
good enough or i'm an imposter or all
these things
these voices that come up um
you know it's good to notice that
they're there and just let them go
and if we spend too much time on them or
we'll spend any time just
just notice them like the wind and let
it go through because
the more we sort of give them attention
the more we're sort of
limiting ourselves so you're also not
attached to other people's opinions
it sounds like too which is a beautiful
place to be it's the best place to be
because
um my i'm here to serve
my audience so um
if i have um you know so so
you know i'll have a bunch of ideas in
my script that i've put down
and when i get feedback i'm it's not me
getting feedback it's like these ideas
came to me they're in service to the
audience
and my job is to sort of get out of the
way whatever the best idea from anywhere
to better serve the audience and so
when i get feedback and criticism if
there's any peace in that that's going
to be more of service to the audience
awesome
and if it's not going to be in service
okay fine thanks for at least
you know trying to give me feedback you
know so
uh does that answer your question it
does yeah
you